let's talk about joy behar for just a
second because this i saw this clip i
was sitting on the beach
why did i open my phone why
i don't know why
it was sitting there was a beautiful day
it's getting sun you can see i got a
little color in my face i was drinking a
margarita i was actually building a
sandcastle i'm getting quite good at the
drip castle with my nieces and nephews
and building really incredible stuff
anyway something happened i picked up my
phone
i have a text message from somebody
you've got to see what joy behar just
said you got to see estimates or 50 000
ukrainians will be dead or wounded and
that this is going to start a
humanitarian crisis a refugee crisis in
europe we're talking about 5 million
people
that that are going to be displaced i
mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there
joy
was that real life
joy behar is worried about her italian
vacation in western europe now first off
this is all happening in eastern europe
but she's really just worried about
herself which is just the perfect
perfect progressive
how does this really affect her and her
vacation which would no doubt be at all
the fanciest hotels we had all the
fanciest restaurants and everything it's
so extraordinarily out of touch
it's just
like it's jaw-dropping it's actually
jaw-dropping what she just said there
just
absolutely
incredible joy i know you live in new
york city go down to italy okay it's in
tribeca and it's a big restaurant and
it's a market and they've got wine and
they've got a cheese section you can get
fresh pasta made you can pretend you're
in italy you'll be okay you crazy loon